I want to share with you a few
simulations that model how an epidemic
spreads there have recently been a few
wonderful interactive articles in this
vein including one in The Washington
Post by Harry Stevens and then another
by kevin similar over at melting asphalt
they are great you can play with them
they're very informative I'll of course
leave links in the description after
seeing those I had a few more questions
like if people stay away from each other
I get that that's gonna slow down the
spread but what if despite mostly
staying away from each other people
still occasionally go to a central
location like a grocery store or a
school also what if you're able to
identify and isolate the cases and if
you can what if a few slip through say
because they don't show symptoms so they
aren't tested how does travel between
separate communities affect things and
what if people avoid contact with each
other for a while but then they kind of
get tired and stopped we'll explore
these questions and more but first let's
walk through how exactly these models
will work each simulation represents
what's called an SAR model meaning the
population is broken up into three
categories those who are susceptible to
getting the disease those who are
infectious and then those who have
recovered from the infection so people
who are immune don't play into it the
way I've written these for every unit of
time that a susceptible person spins
within a certain infection radius of
someone with the disease they'll have
some probability of contracting it
themselves so we're using physical
proximity as a stand-in for things like
shaking hands touching the same surface
kissing sneezing on each other all that
good stuff then for each infectious
person after some amount of time they'll
recover and no longer be able to spread
the disease or if they die they also
won't be able to spread it anymore
so as a more generic term sometimes
people consider the R and s AR to stand
for remove
this should go without saying but let me
emphasize it at the start anyway these
are toy models with a tiny population
inevitably falling far short of the
complexities and real people and larger
populations I am NOT an epidemiologist
so I would be very hesitant to
generalize any of the lessons here
without deeper consideration that said I
think it can be healthy to engage the
little scientist inside all of us and
take the chance to be experimental and
quantitative even if it's in a
necessarily limited fashion especially
if the alternative is to dwell on
headlines and uncertainty well start
things simple and layer on more
complexity gradually in these first few
runs that you're looking at everybody is
simply meandering around the city in a
kind of random walk and the infection
follows the rules that we've laid out so
it doesn't look great
after not too long almost everybody gets
infected as a sanity check what would
you expect to happen if I double this
radius of infection you might think of
this as representing more total
interactions between people or a more
socially engaged society it'll spread
more quickly of course but how much it's
actually very drastic within a short
time span the majority of our little
population is infected simultaneously as
another sanity check what would you
expect if we go back to the original
infection radius and then we cut the
probability of infection in half
remember the way this is running for
each day that a susceptible person is
within that radius of an infectious
person they have some probability of
becoming infected by default I've set it
to 20 percent but this is the number
that we're now going to cut in half you
might think of this as better
hand-washing better cough protection and
less face touching
as you might expect it spreads out the
curve in fact it does this by quite a
lot which really illustrates how changes
to Hygiene have very large effects on
the rate of spreading the first of
several key takeaways here that I'd like
you to tuck away in your mind is just
how sensitive this growth can be to each
parameter in our control it's not that
hard to imagine changing your daily
habits in a way that multiplies the
number of people you interact with or
that cuts your probability of catching
an infection in half but the
implications for the pace of the spread
are huge the goal is probably to reduce
the total number of people who die which
is going to be some proportion of this
removed category in the end that
proportion is not a constant though if
you get to a point where the peak of the
infection curve is too high meaning
there's a time when many people are all
sick at once that's the point when
available healthcare resources are
overwhelmed which for a bad disease will
increase the mortality rate now I don't
know where you're from but in most towns
people don't actually spend their days
drunkenly wandering around the city like
this often there's a common destination
like a Central Market or school in our
model if we introduce some central spot
like this that people regularly visit
and then return from it's well just look
one of the main things I was curious
about is how to mitigate this effect and
that's something we'll examine in just a
bit another feature that we could
include is to have a few separate
communities with transit between them
every day each person will have some
probability of traveling to the center
of another community and then going
about their usual routine from there all
of that is our basic set up so now the
question is what actions help to stop
this spread
what is by far most effective is to
identify and isolate whoever is
infectious for example with good testing
and quick responsiveness in our
simulations once we hit some critical
threshold of cases we're going to start
sending people to a separate location
one day after they have the infection
this is of course a stand-in for
whatever isolation would look like in
the real world it doesn't have to
literally be transporting all the sick
people into one sad box unsurprisingly
this totally halts the epidemic in its
tracks but what if when you're infected
you have a 20 percent chance of not
getting quarantined say because you show
no symptoms so you don't get tested and
you go about your day as usual we're
gonna illustrate these people that have
no symptoms using yellow circles instead
of red obviously this will have a result
somewhere between a total quarantine and
doing nothing but where on the spectrum
would you predict it'll be
[Music]
the peak number of simultaneous cases is
only a little bit higher but there is a
very long tail as it takes a much longer
time to stamp out resulting in about
twice as many total cases this gets more
interesting when we do it in a setting
with many communities and transit
between them again
totally effective tracking and isolation
stops the epidemic very quickly but what
would you predict is gonna happen if now
20 percent of the infectious cases slip
through that process again I've set
things to wait until a certain critical
threshold of cases is hit before our
little dot society kicks into gear and
takes action as a side note it's a
little interesting that even when all
the parameters are the same some runs
take three times longer to reach this
point than others before the law of
large numbers kicks in that pace of
growth can have as much to do with a
roll of the dice as it does with
anything intrinsic to the disease itself
this leaky quarantine een effort
definitely flattens out the curve but it
is a much thicker tale and it takes a
much longer time to track down all the
cases with over half the population
getting infected this time now what
would you predict if it was only 50% of
the infectious cases that were isolated
like this if half the infectious people
are getting quarantined it doesn't mean
that half the total population will end
up with the disease because there are so
many agents still out there spreading it
we end up with a situation that's only
barely better than if nothing had been
done at all a second key takeaway here
is that changes in how many people slip
through the tests can cause
disproportionately large changes to the
total number of people infected if we
look back to the fact that quickly
containing cases so early is so
effective it actually has an interesting
corollary which is that the most lethal
diseases are in some sense less
dangerous globally remember that the
rule of this quarantine simulation is to
send infectious people to a separate
spot one day after they've been infected
but if the disease kills its host after
one day the model looks identical
it just has a much darker interpretation
it is terrible for those who get it but
it doesn't spread it also means that the
most dangerous viruses are the ones that
kill some part of the population while
laying unnoticed and spreadable among
others or worse yet if they remain
unnoticed and spreadable in everyone
before eventually becoming lethal one of
the reasons that the SARS outbreak in
2002 was so well contained is that just
about everybody in this infectious
population was showing symptoms so they
were much easier to identify and isolate
a more optimistic corollary of these
quarantine simulations is how useful
early treatment can be if there exists
an antiviral therapeutic that can move
people out of this infectious category
quickly it has the same effect on the
model as isolating those cases but let's
say you don't have widespread testing or
antiviral therapeutics
well let's introduce a new parameter
here which is how much people try to
avoid each other let's call it the
social distance factor in these
animations I'll apply it as a repulsive
force between people and have them glow
yellow when they feel just a little too
close to their neighbor this has the sad
but kind of cute effect that when our
little agents are social distancing they
often end up trembling near the edge of
their box no isolation is perfect though
so every now and then even though is
repulsed by each other we'll kind of
jiggle close enough to get infected the
point is that those interactions are
much rarer let's take a look at four
separate runs here in each one of them
after we hit 50 cases I'll turn on
social distancing but in the top left
we'll turn it on for everybody in the
top right we'll turn it on for 90% of
the population in the bottom left for
70% of the population and in the bottom
right for only half the population what
would you predict is going to happen
as you might expect when 100% of people
avoid each other the disease quickly
goes away entirely and in all four cases
the presence of some kind of widespread
social distancing definitely flattens
out the curve however in terms of the
ultimate number of cases the run with
70% and even the one with 90% end up
with a little less than half the
population ultimately getting infected
which is only a tiny bit better than the
one with 50% that case with 90% of
people repelling each other
certainly takes longer to get there but
evidently a mere 10% of the population
cheating adds enough instability to our
system to keep the fire slowly burning
for a long time again I'll emphasize
that these are toy models and I leave it
to the intelligence of the viewer to
judge if the behavior of these little
dots accurately reflects what social
distancing would mean for you and your
life someone fully sequestered in their
home is not necessarily affected by the
random jiggling z' of their neighbor but
then again few of us genuinely live
independently from everyone else insofar
as these models aren't outlandish the
third key takeaway is that social
distancing absolutely works to flatten
the curve but even small imperfections
prolonged the spread for a while
now let's look at that setup with 12
communities and travel between them by
default I have it set so that every day
each agent has a 2% chance of travelling
to the center of a different community
now let's try a run where once we hit a
hundred cases we cut down that travel
rate by a factor of four to only half a
percent what would you predict is going
to happen the honest answer is that it
depends in some runs it doesn't make any
difference and the majority of every
community gets it other times there are
a couple communities that end up
unscathed in general the earlier you
turn on this effect the more effective
it is but the takeaway here is the
reducing contact between communities
really has only a limited effect once
those communities already have it and as
solutions go it's certainly not robust
on its own
as a sidenote when we run these
simulations with larger cities which has
the effect that city centers act like
concentrated urban hubs you can see how
as soon as the infection hits one of
these urban centers it very quickly hits
all of them and after that it slowly
spreads to the edges of each community
[Music]
let's take a moment to talk about how to
quantify this spread consider one person
with the disease and then count how many
people they infect while they have it
the average for this count across
everybody who's been sick is known as
the effective reproductive number or our
a more commonly discussed number is R
naught which is the value of R in a
fully susceptible population like at the
very beginning this is known as the
basic reproductive number you may have
noticed I have this little label on our
simulations and the way that it's being
calculated is to look at each individual
who's currently infectious count how
many people they've infected so far
estimate how many they're going to
infect in total based on the duration of
the illness and then average those
numbers
for example in our first default
simulation with no added spices our is
around 2.2 at the highest part of the
growth phase before falling down as the
population becomes saturated by contrast
when we doubled the infection radius our
was as high as 8 this factor has a huge
effect on the growth rate it should kind
of make sense that it jumped up as high
as 8 though when you double that radius
there's about four times as many people
inside it to infect when we chopped the
infection rate in half it hovered around
the 1.3 to 1.7 range while our is
greater than 1 the infection is growing
exponentially and it's at that point
that it's known as an epidemic when it
holds steady around 1 that's when a
disease is called endemic and less than
1 means that it's on the decline for
comparison are not for kovat 19 is
estimated to be a little above 2 which
is also around what the mean estimate
for R naught was during the 1918 Spanish
flu pandemic the seasonal flu by
comparison is much lower around 1.3 in
the travel case as soon as we turn on
social distancing and shut down travel
you can see are quickly dropped down
from 2 there's a little bit of a lag
between the change we make to the model
and the value of this number since it's
calculated based on current infectious
cases which might have existed prior to
the method being put in place like I
said at the start one of the things I
was most curious about is the effect of
some kind of shared central location
like a market or school when I
introduced such a destination for our
little dots are not jumps as high as 5.8
this might be a little unfair since it
puts everyone right in the same spot and
given that we're using physical
proximity as a stand-in for things like
shaking hands or kissing we should maybe
acknowledge that people going to the
same school or grocery store are not as
likely to spread an infection as say
close friends or people living in the
same house to account for this
let's conservatively cut the probability
of infection per day in half this does
indeed cut our knot in half but the
effect of a central market remains
dramatic now let's try a run where after
some threshold is hit we turn on social
distancing but people still go to that
central location the way they did before
[Music]
you may notice that some of our little
thoughts seem to have escaped their
little cage which was not supposed to
happen but I'm going to make the
conscious choice not to fix that it's
like they all looked at the chaos inside
and just win nope I'm out I don't want
any part of that living in the Bay Area
during a shelter-in-place order I can
confirm that this is how some people
react wandering dots aside though let me
show you how this graph compares to the
control case where we did nothing and
how it compares to what would have
happened if in addition to repelling
from each other all of the dots also
stopped going to that central location
the peak of the infection curve is a
little bit lower than the control but in
terms of the total number of cases
keeping that central location active
really defeats the effects of otherwise
social distancing now let me ask you to
make a prediction what do you think will
be more effective if on top of that
social distancing effect we decrease the
frequency with which people go to that
central spot maybe by a factor of five
or if we chop the probability of
infection down by another factor of two
for example meaning people are super
extra cautious about washing their hands
and not touching their face
the simulation on the Left requires our
dots to very heavily alter their daily
routines whereas on the right our dots
can mostly continue their usual habits
but they're just much more conscious of
hygiene they're actually nearly
identical which surprised me given that
one of them is a fivefold decrease and
the other is twofold
I guess it goes to show that effective
hygiene which is maybe easier said than
done really goes a long way of course it
doesn't have to be in either/or our goal
with these experiments is to look at the
effects of one change at a time
if you're curious here's what it looks
like when we apply social distancing we
restrict the rate that people go to the
central location and we also lower the
infection rate all at once this
combination is indeed very effective but
I want to emphasize again how the most
desirable case is when you can
consistently identify and isolate cases
even in this central market simulation
which left unchecked gives a huge
conflagration being able to do this
effectively still halts the epidemic and
our little dots don't even have to be
repelled by each other or stop their
trips to the central spot in real
epidemiology by the way it gets way more
sophisticated than this with tactics
like contact tracing where you not only
identify and isolate known cases but you
do the same for everyone who's been in
contact with those cases given the time
that I'm posting this I imagine there's
some expectation for it to be a PSA on
social distancing but to be honest
that's not really my own main takeaway
to be clear when it's needed like it is
now social distancing absolutely saves
lives and as we saw earlier when people
cheat or when they continue to regularly
meet at a central spot it has a
disproportionate effect on the long term
number of cases the uncomfortable truth
though is that while the disease still
exists as soon as people let up and they
go back to their normal lives if nothing
is in place to contain the cases few
though they might be you'll just get a
second wave
after making all of these what I came
away with more than anything else
was a deeper appreciation for Disease
Control done right for the inordinate
value of early widespread testing and
the ability to isolate cases for
therapeutics that treat these cases and
most importantly for how easy it is to
underestimate all that value when times
are good I'm writing this during a
pandemic when some viewers may be able
to identify a little too well with the
trembling dots for treating to the edge
of their box but in the future many
people will be watching this during a
pandemic that never was a time when a
novel pathogen that could have spread
widely if left unchecked was instead
swiftly found and contained those would
be pandemics never make it into the
history books which is maybe why we
don't value the heroes behind them the
way that we should living in a world
with widespread travel and vibrant urban
centers does make fighting the spread of
a disease an uphill battle that's
absolutely true but that same level of
connectedness means that ideas spread
more quickly than ever
ideas that can lead to systems and
technologies that nip these outbreaks in
the bud
it won't happen on its own and it's
clear that we sometimes make mistakes
but I'm fundamentally optimistic about
our ability to learn from those mistakes
as you might imagine these videos
require a lot of hours of effort I don't
do any ad reads at the end and YouTube
content related to the current pandemic
seems to be systematically demonetised
so I just want to take this chance to
say a particularly warm thank you to
those who support them directly on
patreon it really does make a difference
[Music]
you